right here in studio man am i right I've
been a fan of viewers for quite some
time and I'll stop talking about you
like you're not sitting here Edward
Norton motherless Brooklyn in theaters
near you coming out on Friday tomorrow
November 1st good to see you sir you too
great to be a great movie great film sir
thank you and a an adaptation of a very
popular book why did you choose this
book to go ahead and direct it and write
it and produce it um because I'm a
greedy actor and I wanted the gig okay
is a great role I mean that honestly
like we definitely in the end expanded
the vision into some some wider
ambitions but in terms of the scope of
the story and all of it but in the
beginning really this this this
character it's it's almost like reading
Catcher in the Rye for the first time
it's like he's you you you get inside
his head and he's so he's such a hot
mess of contradictions he's smart and
and sensitive but he's also like
afflicted with Tourette syndrome and he
he's so it's funny you're wincing you're
laughing you're you actually feel
empathy for what's hard about it and
it's just he's just a fascinating ride
and when I read it I was like you know
that's one of those roles you're you
literally go could I even do that right
you know and and that that and and so
it's it started with dad and then it
became well how do you take this very
this book that's wonderful but a very
interior experience inside a guy's head
how do you make that a movie and if you
can make it a movie what you know what
more do you go for in it and and it sort
of it evolved for me over time and it's
a fascinating time in the history of the
city of New York yeah well where you are
revealing a lot of obviously graft
corruption but the making of the city
and a I guess so for anybody who knows
New York City or Robert Moses type
character that I've got Baldwin place so
expertly and it's just a lush film where
that you you you nail the time period
thank you I you know I wanted to go for
one of those I mean there's that there's
a certain point I if you're lucky and
your career you say well
you know one of the movies I like to see
what what do I like what do I wish there
was more of our well and I why don't I
try to make one and and I think for all
of us like you know the experience of an
LA Confidential or or Chinatown or even
things that aren't Noir or detective
things like Unforgiven or or you know
something that that where it's you don't
even really think back on the plot what
you remember is the experience that that
movie magic experience where your your
brain goes whoa this looks right it's
big it's deep the the music is great the
actors are weighty and things and your
something flicks in your head and you
say this all feels right and grown up
and I'm just in you know this hypnosis
happens and you just are happy to be
there you're happy to be on the ride and
um the Godfather was like that for me I
mean way the first time you saw the
Godfather it's very it's partly the
story but a lot of it is just just the
the bigness of it you know and um and
the fact that it's that many great
actors and and I wanted to take I wanted
to take a shot at making one of those
Edward Norton here on the Rich Eisen
show cast is amazing
um one of my favorite people that I
actually have known and he has sat in
this chair a guest host of the show
Bobby Cannavale II oh yeah and I snapped
a photograph of him as I was watching it
at home you know cuz I got a link to
watch it took a picture of him like I'm
watching you right now and motherless
Brooklyn and he writes back about the
Jets because he was you know the Jets
were screwing it up yes Night Football
and that's a nice that's a polite well
his mother was jet fan I guess anyway
right there he's amazing in it and
obviously so is Bruce Willis Willem
Dafoe Alec Baldwin just yeah he crushed
it crashing but also again for those of
us you know Alec Alec you know you know
how the Greek the Greek masks of drama
are like the the comedy and the tragedy
that's Alec is one of those actors who's
got it both he the fact that he's this
great comedic and satirical actor right
which not lots of great dramatic actors
have those chops he has both but I've
never lost sight of the fact
you know the Alec that we loved in
Glengarry Glen Ross you know Coffee is
for closers only like that I mean if
there was ever a more iconic yeah kind
of a forceful bully than that moment in
that film I don't know what it is and I
um when I was coming up in New York he
was doing streetcar on Broadway and
people were like yeah let's see you step
into Brando shoes and I remember going
and singing and going oh my god he owns
this it's like he and he's he has that
that that wait we were we were talking
about Carl Reiner and Mel Brooks but in
that era like it's likely Jakob you know
like people people from those movies
like on the waterfront who feel like
they are cut right out of the New York
Street duel Angry Men yeah something
like that
Alec has that for me he's always had
that and when I thought about who's the
ultimate New York power boss who's
lethally charming and lethally
intimidating - that's him that's him
that was it was and he's and he just he
crushes it he does in this it does yeah
and I mean another I guess serious
comedic role he his role in The Departed
at odd times where he would own the
scene and yet be I would be laughing out
loud sometimes with the way that he has
because I think isn't it a funny thing
there are times when when there's times
when if something's really great someone
can be saying something that's cruel or
grotesque right but the language is so
good and they are they own it so well
you laugh laughing is the strangest
response but sometimes you just laugh at
the delight of how how muscular right
rich it is you know and he says some
things in the end of this film and this
kind of dark soliloquy in the pool yes
um some of which I can't repeat but he
but but it's almost like the
unapologetic like it makes you sort of
almost like laugh in horror you know
what I mean well it's interesting I
again Edward Norton here in the Richard
show I had the benefit of watching it on
on a link and I know that that's not
what a director wants but I'm saying the
reason why I'm bringing it up here is I
watched
soliloquy a second time yeah it was that
good yeah and as I wanted I just wanted
to see how he he just he chewed it up
like and there's times to their there
are literally times like there's a
there's a bit in there where it doesn't
ruin anything he said he says you know
if some if some guy wants to blackjack
me you know threatening to move our
baseball team then the Dodgers can take
it on the arches to the F in space it's
Japan and I couldn't imagine anyone
saying that like him I felt that way
about kind of ollie too like there's
certain lines in there he Bobby says at
one point like I know it's cold that's
why they call it winter right you know
and you can't you he's a lot of people's
mouths I don't think I could pull off
the line the way he can there's there's
just an authenticity to some actors that
they can um they can do things that
other people can't do Edward Norton here
on the Rich Eisen show and let's let's
talk a little bit of comedy here because
the gentleman across the way right there
Chris Brockman his significant other was
a writer on the roast for Bruce Willis
Sarah Tiana who told us that you are the
only one that they have written jokes
for that when it got punched up it was
funnier meaning when I punched you
punched it up when you took you you got
so I mean obviously you had those chops
as well well right you know in a funny
way I give I flipped the compliment back
to them you know you I I always think
people who aren't comedians shouldn't
shouldn't dilettante usually think that
they can do what comedians do and I sort
of felt going into that that the best
thing to do was write something write
something that's more like me being me
having fun you know sure sending up
yourself instead of trying to like trade
zingers with Jeff Ross that isn't a
recipe for being like cut down by a
samurai sword to prime left as a garnish
on a salad you know what I mean like the
the the better thing to do is almost act
like you're playing it straight that's
Anna and I think what what I knew I had
certain I had I had certain angles on it
that were my own that I think um you
know it also by the way it mixes it up a
little bit it's it's it's good
have something that comes in a show like
that you're gonna get a lot of great
comedians from but I think having
something that that plays at a different
rhythm is a it's part of why people
enjoy I love roast
I mean roast to me are there it's an
unbreakable form at a plus they gave me
some great lines too I can't take credit
for like you know there was a really
good line about um you know how I turned
to Wes Anderson and said shut up you
long-haired you know something that is a
movie star when did you first meet Bruce
Willis when did you first ever cross
paths well he's in this movie he's
terrific in it as well he's terrific in
it and I it's a it you know what it's
I'm happy to tell that story because he
I sort of mentioned it on that roast but
insincerity Bruce saw me in a play many
years ago 17 years ago he saw me in a
play in New York and I got home in the
night after the show and there was a
letter from him that was so thoughtful
and and amazing about the play and about
the thing I called him and said thank
you you know and he said let's get a
beer and we talked and he said look I do
what I do but I came up in New York I
came thing I want to do work like that
and if you're if you've got something
that I can be and I'm in they gave me
said I really want you to call me and I
thought you know yours all these years
later I was like he's he's gonna say he
oh thanks kid but I get you know I got
die hard coming up and you know what I
mean and he he said I'm in and I said
well you should read it and he goes no I
will but I told you I'm in and I'm I'm
in and I he anchored the film at I got
the film put together with the studio
and I he helped me get the money to put
the film together and he did it for no
money so I literally could it's not even
that he's great in the film and that
he's a big part of the emotional anchor
cuz cuz his relationship in my
character's relationship is is what
makes you understand why this guy's
doing what he does for the rest of the
film right and and and and him being
bruised him being the guy he is is part
of what makes it work and but I couldn't
have gotten the movie made without his
support and Alec and Willem and all
these great actors came together and did
this movie for me for no money they did
- for the love of the piece which is and
it's amazing it really is amazing
motherless Brooklyn in theaters on
Friday and since you know Bruce Willis
I'm gonna go here right now Chris and
you're a filmmaker and you are an actor
with trophies in the case
do you consider diehard a Christmas
movie would you say that is a Christmas
movie Edward Norton emphatically yes
thank you Edward oh my gosh I hated once
again I mean okay I I do not I do not
why do you feel that way so I'm I'll
tell you why because it fits in it with
my dad on you know who worked really
hard and so the Christmas holiday was
you know it was a real it was a fun time
to sit back on the on the couch and we
would watch movies like the Dirty Dozen
and The Great Escape and and and I think
it's one of those I think it's uh not
just because he wears the Santa hat but
because uh because it's what I associate
it's it's the fun kind of movie that I
associate with over the holidays finally
having some time to sit back and watch a
movie with my dad cuz to me you know a
Christmas movie is about angels it's
about yeah the holiday spirit it's about
a miracle happening it's about feel good
yeah okay and and I think it's a
wonderful life that's what I yes yes I
don't think of Hans Gruber trying to
blow up NACA Thome Plaza I'm saying
that's that's the that's where I'm
coming from yeah no I I that that's a
completely rational okay argument I I
I get why you think right just because
there's a holiday party and they're
playing music and as you say you know
hohoho I have a machine gun is it great
why I just don't that's where I'm coming
from yeah yeah no I I eat it this way if
you said to me does die hard to have the
Christmas spirit and I would say no okay
yeah see now we're getting I think we
can agree to disagree because Jake
Tapper the screenwriter I think Steven
D'Souza um they're all like yes
emphatically Christmas movie I say
absolutely not and Bruce Willis as you
know at the end of his
I don't know if you saw his roast yeah
you were yeah yeah that's not the line
that he said at the end yeah
yippie-ki-yay right no he said that a
good died heart is not a Christmas movie
oh he he did for him by his significant
other so I guess we're coming full
circle on that front I I think that
there's there's you know part of the if
you're really lucky and you get to have
a career and work with various people
sometimes you really like like getting
to work with Bruce getting to work with
Alec getting to work with Willem Dafoe
like mmm those are those are people I
came up on sure and you know and and
idolized in different ways
Willem was Willem was the quintessential
New York theater actor who still had his
own theater company and went off and was
a movie star and an Academy
award-winning actor and in platoon yeah
but like me and Phil Hoffman and and
Bobby and Mark Ruffalo and everyone who
went to New York to be actors and was in
theater companies will and was Willem
was like if you could have that kind of
career where you kept the straddle
between the that's it you know what I
mean and um and I and getting to you
know getting to like direct and work
with him that was like a peak experience
for me well a few minutes I have left
here I want to go through we have a
segment here called celebrity true or
false where there are stories about your
career that we just want to know if
they're true or not just because they're
on the internet so hit hit hit hit the
drop here Mike
whose celebrity true or false
that's our drop with Edward Norton first
one up you took soap making classes with
Brad Pitt during the filming of Fight
Club is that that is true yeah okay
what is what is a class like that looked
like what is it experience to take a
soap making class with Brad Pitt like in
in the it's sort of like probably
something that would run on goop now it
was very it was me and Brad in a couple
of people who are artisanal soap makers
and we had a blast okay
it was great um did you can you still
make stuff from so not that complicated
it's um it's slightly more complicated
than making cookies you can burn
yourself with the lye so you have to
wear gloves and hair careful okay and
there's you know there's vegetable based
soaps and then there's ones that still
use like like here I mean like my gosh
years later it's like you know it was um
okay we did we would do our soap making
and then go over for our muy Thai
classes in succession but one after
another yeah with some time still with
the you know with the actually the
glycerin you know interesting to when
you're grappling later and sure I love
them you can't do the jujitsu hold
because of the so it's not like Fight
Club you can talk about so making
classes yeah what years later okay very
good
next up when you played in the World
Series of Poker with Matt Damon to prep
for the role of worm and rounders I we
played in the World Series Matt and I
not to prep weed after the shoot the the
we were done with the film no kidding
it was part of the run up promoting the
film so yes we played as part we played
in the promotional run-up to the film
coming out and so obviously the movie
the movie studio fronted you the fake
correct I believe I believe they did I
believe they did either they did or the
tournament did because in that era like
it was not sexy it was not like that
like they didn't have a lot of
celebrities coming to play poker and
Matt and I weren't even like big
celebrities per se we
we were what they could get no lasted
longer you were mad you know what we we
both did okay and we both had very jerk
we both played along well mmm and the
coaching we'd gotten from Johnny Chan
and Phil Hellmuth's and a lot of these
other guys stood us in good stead and I
got some good cards and won a few hands
and um everything we both had very like
dramatic exits I I actually played a
Johnny Chan tip I played pocket nines
when I was on the button and ended up
with kind of I bet it as though it was
an ace king or something like that
I got a middle flop I got a nine and a
ten and then I got a second ten so I had
I had a pretty much unreadable Full
House yes and I got beat by four tens
get out of here I a guy named sir and
are saying he quat attends against
against an unreadable full house and
when I called and I had more chips than
him when I flipped the boat the whole
table exploded they were like he's going
to take Sardar Singh out of the
tournament and he flipped quad tens it
was incredible I was going to say do you
remember the hand do not know where
details of it to but but he said to me
later he goes he goes on ninety-nine out
of a hundred times he goes you dove not
he gets out I had no idea that you had
that hand I'm blown away he's worse
[Laughter]
we're talking about it and I'm having
the Saving Private Ryan
everything goes silent again and you
know I was trying to play it off even a
gutshot when they talk about being gut
shot I was got shot definition and
that's wasn't that Matt Matt played Matt
went all-in before the flop on Kings
pocket kings against Doyle Brunson
Brunson had pocket aces Matt had pocket
kings and nothing came up and and and he
got beat you know on a ace king right I
mean flop roll out by Doyle Brunson but
that's now you've got to make a rounders
two right so you can get back in there
and lock the compliment in Laveen it's
all with them well you know it's
interesting that you say that because
you know I was in an episode of billions
Edward Norton this past year so I know
what it's like to read compliment and
lavinia written line yeah so they're
masters they would I everyone said like
you said it I think Matt Damon has said
it these guys have said it so let's just
get everyone together and do it yeah
it's um you know I the color of money is
to me the greatest example of why it's
worth waiting right yes like it's
because it was a long time later it was
connected to the hustler but there was
like it had something to it because he
was so much older right yes so I think
that I actually think like people say Oh
will there be a Fight Club to this we're
all it's like shut up that's just an
urban myth that's ridiculous but
rounders I don't think it we run serious
about it I just think it should be right
it should be they should be in a
different phase of their life and I
think worm obviously has to have been
involved in the credit default swaps
rounders too he's been working for the
GR you to get Trump elected I don't know
what he's been he's been he's been in
the game in the fringes that's all your
true or false question yeah I mean I've
got one last one if you have time for it
we've got it to last one is you
developed your twang for your
oscar-nominated performance and primal
fear by watching the film that
coalminers daughter that's true yeah III
my family my people are originally from
Eastern Kentucky but but the accent
isn't really in our family anymore
and so I [ __ ] Spacek and Tommy Lee
Jones in that film yeah are doing a
really really good kind of Appalachian
thing and I thought that seemed that
seemed right like that's how you liked
it up yeah like a poor little rube you
know that so I'm glad that so most of
these are true but those are true yeah
that's odd and since you like Reiner and
Mel Brooks I do my favorite my favorite
note I ever got from a director was on
Fight Club when I'm like we were I was
doing one of the things like in wingtips
and the underwear running away whatever
sort of funny but yeah and anyway
Fincher came over to me and he goes a
little less Jerry a little more Dean I
was like I know I that's it that's don't
say anything else for the rest of the
film all you have to do is say Jerry
Dean like more dean little less less
Jerry a little more Dean makes sense
yeah and don't but you know what that
means right yeah I'd like just a little
a little bit more a little more
not quite so not not quite so goofy yes
I mean and that was kind of that became
almost like the meter for that whole
film
well motherless Brooklyn is an
outstanding movie I suggest everybody go
see it when it's in theaters tomorrow
you're great in it and so is everybody
else I can't rave about it enough thank
you I really appreciate you coming on
here that was fun like I said I have
been a big fan for for quite some time
at Edward Norton on Twitter and at
Edward Norton official on Instagram
should you choose to follow Edward
Norton on on any of those social media
outlets good to see you sir great yeah
thank you thank you Edward Norton right
here on the Rich Eisen show we'll close
up shop in a moment for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on Direct TV for free on BR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app